-Guys, you may have heard
about this,
but the website Yahoo! Answers
just announced
that they're shutting
down forever.
[ Audience groans ]
And it really -- it's really
difficult news,
because one of my favorite
groups is the Yahoo! --
Yahoo! Answers lounge singers.
[ Laughter ]
They're one
of my favorite groups.
They sing real Yahoo! Answers
submitted by real people.
So, if you don't mind,
I booked them on the show
to perform one last time.
Here they are, the
Yahoo! Answers lounge singers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, Ronda.
-Hi, Kad.
How's it going?
-Yeah. It's going great.
I got some questions
that need answered.
-Alrighty, well, I'm going
to see what I can do.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Can someone please give me a
Netflix username and password? ♪
-♪ Just give me $10 a month ♪
♪ And I'll give you my
name and password ♪
-Oh, hey, I like that answer.
-Yeah, I like that question.
-Alright.
Well, how about this one?
♪ Is Christian Bale
a Christian ♪
♪ Since his name is Christian? ♪
-♪ Is Mitt Romney
a baseball glove? ♪
-Now that --
now that is a good point.
-Yeah,
that's a good point, Kas.
-Kad.
-Kad is my friend.
-This next one makes
a good point as well.
♪ Which is worse? ♪
♪ Ignorance or apathy ♪
-♪ I don't know
and I don't care ♪
-Oh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
That -- that stings.
-Yeah, it stings.
It stings worse
than a shook up beehive.
You know what that is.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah
-Yeah.
-You can say that again.
-It's when you take a bunch
of bees and you shake them,
and the last one that stings
you, you got to marry him.
-Let's -- let's see how spicy
this next question is.
♪ How many fingers
am I holding up? ♪
♪ Depends... ♪
♪ Are you angry? ♪
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
I'm glad --
I'm glad you're here
to answer my questions.
-And I'm happy as pie
to be answering them,
and I think we
know what that means,
the saying.
[ Laughter ]
[ Piano solo ]
♪♪
Oh, get into it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I got another one for you.
-Lay it on me,
my inquisitive friend Kad.
-♪ Why do chips get stale? ♪
-♪ Thog don't care ♪
-Thog? Thog wrote that?
-Classic Thog.
Thog wrote that indeed.
-I wonder if Thog
wrote this next one.
-Oh. [ Giggles ]
-♪ How do you get YouTube
to come film you? ♪
-♪ Just keep on calling ♪
♪ And soon they will respond ♪
[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-That took a turn.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, I just got
to find it sometimes, but I do.
I do.
I find it in my own time.
-Yeah, you got it.
I got one more question,
if you've got some time.
-Oh, yeah, I'm going nowhere.
I live here.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah?
-I live in here.
-Okay, perfect.
♪ Has anyone ever held their
breath for over an hour? ♪
-♪ Yes ♪
♪ Dead people ♪
-That is all our time, folks.
Thanks for having us.
We'll be right back with more
of "The Tonight Show."
Why do I say that?
We're not on "The Tonight Show."
Oh, we are, we are!
Hey, Jimmy!
Hey, say hi.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my goodness.
-I'm a big fan.
[ Cheers and applause ]